la campagne présidentielle qui se joue
beaucoup en province en ce moment
emmanuel macron pas encore en lice est
officiellement candidat à sa réélection
lui non plus a choisi montpellier pour
ouvrir demain sa nouvelle formule du
sommet afrique france le président qui a
choisi de l'inviter aucun de ses
homologues africains on retrouvera
montpellier samantha hammami notre
envoyé spécial pour le sommet bonsoir
samantha alors le sommet france-afrique
tente de se renouveler c'est bien ça
bonsoir stéphanie alors vous faites bien
de dire tente de se renouveler vous
n'êtes pas dupe en tout cas ce qui se
renouvelle ses cartes et france n'est
toujours pas accréditer lorsque emmanuel
macron initie un rendez vous au moment
où je vous parle nous ne sommes pas
accrédités pour couvrir ce sommet ce
nouveau sommet afrique france demain
nous nous rendrons sur place au sud
arena et nous vous tiendrons au courant
en tous les cas dans l'entourage de la
présidence et au niveau même inde
emmanuel macron l'assurent il s'agit de
se parler sans tabou donc c'est vrai un
format inédit un nouveau sommet
afrique-france la sémantique là elle est
importante on insiste beaucoup sur le
terme nouveau alors c'est vrai c'est une
première il n'y a aucun chef d'état
invité demain donc place à la société
civile et à la jeunesse on a on annonce
la participation de 3000 personnes dont
un millier de jeunes 350 entrepreneurs
si nous ne sommes pas accréditée en tout
cas nous avons bien reçu le programme je
vous l'assuré je l'aimé bien ce côté ça
me semble quand même un petit peu trop
chargé pour une seule journée il ya
beaucoup de conférences des conférences
économiques
culturels scientifiques sportives même
comme si finalement on pouvait
concentrer le meilleur de l'afrique en
une journée donc voilà pour la forme
reste à savoir si cela va réellement
impacté le les fondements de la relation
afrique-france beaucoup en doutent
d'ailleurs en parallèle se déroule ici à
montpellier un contre sommet sur
plusieurs jours à l'initiative d'un
collectif d'associations on y retrouve
l'association attac de lutte contre la
corruption les ong survie décoller des
collectifs panafricain des collectifs de
défense des sans-papiers l'objectif
c'est de dénoncer les maux de la
françafrique de dénoncer la continuité
de la politique française sur le
continent africain sur les plans
économique monétaire avec une réforme du
franc cfa qui piétine et sur le plan
aussi migratoires sachez stéphanie qu'on
a appris aujourd'hui via un communiqué
de ce collectif du contre sommet que des
militants en faveur des sans papiers ont
été arrêtés à la gare de montpellier à
la descente de leurs trains en
provenance de paris et samantha quels
sont les enjeux de ce nouveau sommet
afrique france justement
alors stéphanie l'enjeu pour emmanuel
macron assez bien évidemment de réussir
son pari dans un contexte délicat de
tension avec le mali mais surtout
l'algérie à un pari loin d'être gagné
sur ces fronts diplomatiques
le message qu emmanuel macron va
adresser à la société civile à la
jeunesse le discours qu'il fera demain
et bien risque en réalité
d'aggraver un peu plus ces crises franco
malienne et et franco algérienne et puis
aussi il y a un problème de crédibilité
si emmanuel macron dissocier les
sociétés à civile des chefs d'état
africains des pouvoirs africains en
réalité il n'en est rien parce qu'en mai
dernier emmanuel macron il a bien convié
tous ses homologues africains à une
grande messe et c'était le sommet sur le
financement en grande pompe il a convié
les homologues africains du pré carré
français mais aussi en dehors de ce pré
carré et c'est vrai que ça ressemblait à
un petit peu à un sommet finalement
afrique france et puis demain autre
exemple demain on attend une délégation
tchadienne il y aura certainement des
activistes à des opposants eh bien on se
souvient encore que emmanuel macron il
n'avait pas hésité à se déplacer pour
assister aux obsèques d'idriss déby au
tchad idriss deby qui est très content
et qui était très contesté par la
population tchadienne pour sa longévité
au pouvoir on sait que le ciasta un
allié stratégique effectivement dans la
lutte antiterroriste mais c'est surtout
un allié stratégique de la france alors
vous le voyez du coup emmanuel macron il
tente effectivement ce pari et puis il
ya aussi on se souvient son discours
devant la jeunesse africaine à
ouagadougou et finalement depuis le
discours de la baule de françois
hollande sur fond d'effondrement de la
chute de l'union soviétique à son
discours à lui et bien rien n'a vraiment
changé puisque il s'agit à chaque fois
de promettre de changer de paradigme
pour une relation afrique-france d'égal
à égal mais en réalité il n'en est rien
alors emmanuel macron qu'est ce qu'il
fait eh bien il a fait appel aux
services
du politologue et historien
camerounais achille mbembe qui a une
aura internationale
l'enjeu pour emmanuel macron
effectivement lorsqu il s'entoure de ce
genre de personnalité il n'est pas le
seul et bien c'est de séduire les pays
anglophones du continent africain qui
n'ont pas vraiment besoin de la france
pour
avancer alors achille mbembe vous savez
il a fondé les saunas panafricaniste il
a fondé les ateliers de la pensée à
dakar avec pour slogan oublions la
france eh bien il a rendu il ya quelques
jours son rapport à emmanuel macron pour
cela il a mené des consultations dans
une dizaine de pays au total 140 pages
avec treize propositions et finalement
des propositions qui sont dans la lignée
des précédents rapports que l'on connaît
le rapport sarr sa voix sur la
restauration du patrimoine africain ou
encore le rapport de benjamin stora sur
les mémoires de la colonisation et de la
guerre d'algérie donc voilà stéphanie
pas certaine en finale que tout cela
toute cette grand'messe change
réellement la donne merci beaucoup
samantha à vos amis en direct de
montpellier alors